so um I'll be talking about the
techniques browser or other engines are
using to compile JavaScript to get the
kind of impressive performance that
we've been getting in the past few years
the original title of my talk suggested
that I would also be giving practical
information about how to write
high-performance JavaScript there will
be less of that in it because actually
the engines are so clever about
optimizing that it's hard to break them
you have to actively try to break their
optimizations so if you're not doing
anything stupid you will get usually
fast code yeah so Brendan introduced me
so you may know me from my book I also
wrote a library code mirror which was
mentioned in the ACE talk before and
last year's J's 1k I wrote the winning
platform game demo thank you
so first I want to give some perspective
about what happens with browser
performance in the past say 15 years so
here we have the dark ages there was
Netscape 4 and there was Internet
Explorer 6 and thanks for our 6 is on
the benchmarks I said too it actually a
little slower than let's get four of us
of course it's supported a lot more
javascript these are by the way well
roughly BAE did the numbers I'm giving
here are completely vague and weird and
you shouldn't take them too seriously
they're based on SunSpider but I
couldn't get SunSpider to run in these
two browsers at all so I did I ran some
of the benchmarks that did run and then
interpolate it to a score to be able to
put these in my graph um wait so then
there's things getting better in the
middle zero Sh
Ajax happens and people started to
actually use JavaScript for more than
window open and document writes people
started to write big complicated systems
in JavaScript and this JavaScript
Foreman's became something serious and
browsers continue to push the envelope
Safari and chrome were very impressive
here the the green bar is Safari orange
is Firefox well maybe you can read this
you can probably read them then we have
this tiny little bar for Chrome there
and then in the last few years you see
all browsers stabilizing on tiny little
bars compared to what we historically
had part of this is that no one wants to
be left behind on this since SunSpider
benchmark scores are they all micro
optimized for SunSpider and this is
should not be taken too seriously but
yeah things definitely got faster I got
a lot faster if you compare to 2001
that's 100 time improvement so of course
this is like diminishing returns you
won't be expecting this kind of speed
ups in the next few years all will be
faster than C in two years but there are
still some things happening and probably
will see another speed-up of two or
three times I come from is that I'm not
writing JavaScript engines so how do
people do this this is also pretty much
the outline of my talk there are four
main things most browsers are compiling
to machine code we're all modern
browsers are compiling to machine count
one way or another there are some
improvements in how values are
represented a very big thing is caching
access to properties so that you can
actually look up object properties
without hashing stuff and looking
through big tables and things like that
garbage collection has been improved
tremendously especially in the past few
years and of course people are gaming
benchmarks for all they can like there
was this this scandal with IE 9 doing
dead couch
but no one knows what exactly happen
because it's close source but it seems
that it only noticed that something was
dead code if it was SunSpider
and maybe they've improved maybe they've
changed I don't really know watch what's
going on there but also brushes are
caching the result of method cosine
because SunSpider calls cosine a lot but
caching that doesn't make any sense in
the general case so they're actually
probably doing it this service to normal
scripts to optimize SunSpider there's
some weird things going on first thing
compilation now the old way the very
simple way to run a JavaScript program
is you parse it you build up like a big
syntax tree and then you run over that's
interpreting the the tree you have
that's something you can implement in a
few days it's probably what Brendan did
back in 1995 but so what you have to do
is for example you resolve variables at
runtime so you you're you're looking up
things in in scopes that you are holding
in memory somehow which have the actual
variable names and it's it's necessarily
terribly slow so no one does that
anymore next step up is you compiled to
bytecode this is usually a pretty
high-level form of code it's relatively
easy and fast to compile to it's small
and you get a lot of benefits of
compilation for examples variables are
results at compile time and during
runtime you're just referring to for
example a stack location and not to a
name that has to be looked at of course
you're still running it through an
interpreter so here's an example there's
a trivial function that adds one to its
second arguments then multiplies it by
its first arguments if we take a
non-existing stack based virtual machine
the the bytecode could look like this
you push one onto the stack you adds the
two top numbers of the stack combine
them into one and replace them by that
number you multiply what's a top of the
stack now and you jump out of function
so you notice that this is like you
reduce a lot of complexity by the
compilation process and well it's not
hard to imagine that interpretation of
this will be much faster than
interpretation of the raw ast3
next step is machine code because then
you don't have any runtime
interpretation at all anymore you're
just letting the Machine run your code
there's there's different approaches I
think VI it compiles everything it gets
down to machine code right away it's
possible to compile on the mount like
live your functions in the raw form and
when they're actually called compile
them what Firefox does is very
interesting it's it's compiled to
bytecode it interprets that but detects
hot loops loops that are run to a lot
and then starts compiling those with
contextual information about the types
of things that are being used there so
it can compile to tighter machine code
than if you're compiling from the
general case but it's a very complicated
complicated technique like they try to
get a whole loop to compile and then
from then on the whole loop can run
without entering bytecode at all anymore
now the reason why JavaScript can be
compiled efficiently at all in contrast
to for example Python is that it is in
the ends largely statically scoped if we
have this card example there are three
variables the compiler can see exactly
where these variables live acts as a
global y&z are arguments to the function
it can decide at compile time where it's
going to store them in a register on the
stack or on some global memory that the
global will probably end up in global
memory and then at runtime it just has
to access that there's some hairiness
with the fact that the global object is
also an object so you can first one will
delete properties from it and it has to
check when it's accessing those
variables whether they have been deleted
but because there's only one global
object it knows the object where it will
be looking at those variables and it can
optimize it pretty well except of course
if you do with this became a completely
dynamic scope when looking up X&Y
it knows that they might be the function
parameters but before getting their
value it always has to go through this
object scope and so it's it's variable
reference in the program within this
scope it's going to take a big hit but
the nice thing is that the compiler can
see statically that there is a width
there and when there is no width it
doesn't have to deal with the whole
construct at all so as long as you don't
use it you don't pay for it mm then
there's of course the other construct
that we would like to talk about evil
that also because it can introduce new
variables into the the scope it
complicates scope handling the scope has
to be more dynamic Russia actually much
faster about handling FL than about
handling with probably because evil is
used in SunSpider and with is not so
there is a motivation for this so then
here we have some beautiful moral
judgments now the first thing with I
actually it's usually turtle to
transform your code to an equivalent
form that doesn't use with and is no
more complicated in it so the only place
I use with is in J's 1k demos then
evolve actually if all does something
that's very useful and you can do
dynamic code loading you can do for
example compiling your templates to
actual scripts and having them be
blazing fast you can do metaprogramming
of some kind we need Evo and the good
news is that there are two kinds of
evolve I mentioned before that the
compiler can statically see whether your
scope is is completely static or not
that means only when eval looks like
there the red thing at the top here when
it's a direct call to the word evolve
then it's a local lexical eval which is
evaluated in the scope of the function
that calls it any other forms like these
weird things below here are indirect
indirect
the compiler can well if it had to
statically determine whether something
is going to evaluate to the eval
function its halting problem so if it
cannot so what it does then this is
actually not mandated by ACMA script
tree but I think ACMA scripts 5 does
mandated you get global evolve if you
treat evolve like a value you get a
function which does a global evolve and
globally fall is much nicer than lexical
avoid doesn't screw up your compilation
it's easier to think about because it
won't override variables in your local
scope well you're still of course
trusting the code that you're evaluating
but usually this is what you want when
you want evolve
the line at the bottom is nicest you
just give it a new name
and from then on you can use that name
to eval things in a more safe way next
thing is failure presentation so in a
dynamic language each value that is
being passed around has to also tell its
type somehow because the code doesn't
know what type it's going to get them it
has to inspect this type to know for
example when the plus operator is
applies what it should do whether it's
concatenating strings or adding numbers
the obvious way to do this is to put
everything on the heap at a type stag
words at the front of the value and then
the actual value itself so you can just
inspect them problem with this is that
you're usually making lots of numbers
for example in your programs mostly
numbers when you do plus you create a
new number and when you're looping
through when you have a loop index
you're creating thousands of numbers
typically allocating those on the heap
is utterly unacceptable and so what you
can do is now that every pointer you
allocate every pointer that is used by
the runtime is allocated by the runtime
and it can it's probably just want to
align those pointers like make sure that
they refer to multiples of four or eight
depending on whether you're on the 32 or
64-bit architecture because accessing
memory words is much much faster when
these words
lines anyway so that means the last two
or three bits of your pointers will be
zero and you can use that to distinguish
between pointers values which have the
type Tec in the pointed to structure and
other values in this case we're going to
represent an integer engines tend to
take care to represent numbers as
integers as long as they can
JavaScript numbers are specified to be
floats 64-bit floating-point numbers but
as long as they are integers smaller
than well in this case 32 bits they can
be represented as integers or two-bit as
long as you detect overflow and switch
to a float at the proper point so what
happens here is that you see these bits
at the bottom the top bit is set to 1 to
indicate if it's an integer and then the
rest of the word is the 32 31 bits that
are remaining is the representation of
the actual numbers shifted to the left
by one bit
it makes arithmetic a bit more involved
but it means you won't have to melech to
create a new number
what Firefox and possibly other engines
is currently doing is representing
everything with 64 bits which has a nice
property that you won't have to box your
floating point numbers heater so those
are also really fast and really direct
the trick is of course that the floating
point number is 64 bits so how do you
use where do you put the the type stack
if you're already using every single
bits for your floating point number
the floating the OEE
I'd have forgot the number the the
standard floating point spec which all
modern architectures are using for their
machine flows defines not a number of
values and actually it defines lots of
those like the last anything that starts
with 7ff for ffff and has not all zeros
after that because all zeros are used
for infinity and minus infinity is not a
number value there was some region III
won't claim to completely understand
this floating point specification but
there was a reason for this the it's
sometimes apparently nice
to have lots of different not a number
of values javascript only needs one did
the average standard just says that
every not a number is an equal to every
other not a number value so that leaves
all these other values for representing
in this case we put the type tag is that
the if you look at the yellow box the
one there would be the type tag and then
you can just put the integer if you need
it certitude bit integer and the
remaining 32 bits at the end if you want
bigger integers you can even use more
bits and then if you use a two type tag
and you put the pointer in the rest of
the value you don't need to box flows
anymore and you have a really convenient
uniform representation where the type
tag is always present in the word itself
without changing pointers I'm told that
this is a great win for Firefox that
they sped things up with this trick then
we proceeded to garbage collection so
here I have a schematic picture of a
heap you can see that the the the grey
rectangle there is supposed to represent
the program that the route pointers of
things that the program is actually
holding onto so I challenge you to tell
me which of these blue dots are no
longer reachable from blue route
pointers here that's not really a
problem um and actually we can see that
there's like one circle that has no
errors at all there because we can just
look at the circle and there are no
arrows around it the runtime has to
actually look at every single one of
these blue dots and make sure that
there's not a pointer in them pointing
at this thing it doesn't have like a
nice high-level overview of this it's
it's difficult to see which which memory
objects are life and which memory
objects are no longer reachable and can
this be collected the usual way to do
this it's called mark-sweep you start at
the roots and you just traverse pointers
and every time you come across an object
you
market with a bit somewhere if you come
across an object that's already marked
you stop otherwise you go through all
its children in the same way and then at
the end everything that's not been
reached is that because you've proven
that you can't reach it this thing is
that while you're approving this you
can't allow anyone to change anything
because it might introduce a new error
which will hook your whole analysis so
typically you are stopping the world
during this collection and it's the root
of the infamous garbage collection
process in JavaScript interpreter while
it's going through its whole memory or
at least all the live memory it doesn't
let the scripts run it doesn't let
anything happen so that's bad there's
some improvement of techniques which do
this incrementally and which detect
whether something changes and retrace
some parts later that helps another
thing that helps is making your heap
smaller some browsers use to represents
to have one heap for all the JavaScript
burning and all the taps that they had
opened the taps and iframes and it's
actually a very natural thing to split
that's per per domain probably because
JavaScript sprout programs are allowed
to access things running on the same
domain so there can be pointers between
deaths but something on a different
domain is almost completely isolated
from from other programs running on
other domains so you can just give them
their own heat that makes the problem
smaller and this makes it much faster to
to to do a collection of course if you
have giants for example an html5 game
which is creating billions of objects in
its own tab then this doesn't save you
because you still have a huge heap to
trash another very successful trick is
generational garbage collection that
means you split the heap into two or
more generations we demonstrated with
two here
because it's quite simple new objects go
into the young generation then when you
collect you just collect a young
generation you promote those objects
sometimes directly sometimes after a few
collections after they've reach a
certain age you promote them to the old
generation and at some point the old
generation gets full so you will have to
do a more expensive collection on the
old generation the problem with this is
that to prove that something in the
young generation is dead is unreachable
you have to be sure that no object in
the old generation is pointing to it so
you have to somehow keep track of all
the pointers going from the old
generation to the new generation which
is which requires some kind of code
around every right you do or a memory
barrier on the pages that holds the old
generations this is tricky but it still
worth it Firefox is planning to move to
generational GCV I'd had it from the
start and it's it's a huge win so here's
some bad pun come saying is is from the
Lisp world word that means allocating
allocating things on the heap and off
lisps you could only create lists on the
heap and lists list cells are called
constants so in the garbage collection
terminology cons is the word for
allocating and but to make something
fast to have your inner loop not cause
GC pauses you should be very careful
about allocating objects in a race and
anything that's going to end up on the
heap they often place to use horrible
dirty tricks like reusing objects and
setting their properties again or
setting Global's instead of returning an
object with several fields one thing to
be aware of is that local functions are
objects which are created every time you
call their like inner functions are
created every time you call their outer
function because they're mutable objects
in JavaScript so they have to be their
own objects
so you have to be careful if you're
calling something a lot don't put in our
functions in it even if they don't close
over anything in the outer function they
will still be stack allocated there are
possibilities to optimize that but I
don't think any engine does it's in my
benchmarks the functions that we're
using inner functions we're much much
lower to call than the function that
were free of inner functions so this is
possibly the most important thing
explaining the current JavaScript speed
properties I said before that scopes are
starting in JavaScript this is great
properties of objects are in no way
static you can dereference anything it
sits there they're prototypes to deal
with it's extremely hard to predict what
an object property dereference is going
to give you so what people are doing
what everyone is doing is inline caching
you can imagine that in the compiled
code there's like a little space next to
each property lookup and when it happens
the code writes well it's it's going to
look the property open an object somehow
and it's going to find the offset into
the object redish property lists at that
point it stores that the kind of the
object and the offset of the property in
this inline cache and the next time it
hits that point it checks first whether
it has a valid cache for this this
lookup if it does it can be very fast
effects usually there's not just
actually in all engines there's not just
one cache they use what's called
polymorphic inline caches today they
have a list of hits so that's even if
you have a few kinds of objects coming
through there it'll still be
successfully cached most of the time the
problem is that there are no classes in
JavaScript so how do you see whether new
objects you get has the same shape as
the object you got the last time around
what people do is synthesize classes
called hidden classes if you know the
prototype of an object and the set of
properties that it has just actually all
you need to know if there are arranged
in the same order
usually inline caches actually only
depend on like the linear order in which
the properties were assigned to the
object because it's much easier to do
what what happens is that such a hidden
class has a list of successor classes so
in this case we start with I should have
capitalized that because it's a
constructor but in this case I you get a
hidden class for this this function
because it this specifies a prototype
for four new objects and does it it will
be its own class when you have an object
of this class so when you call new
points it creates an empty objects of
this class and you assigned to its X it
looks up in this hidden class in the
list of successor classes whether
there's one that's created by assigning
X if it is then it takes that Clause if
not it creates a new class and adds it
to the list and the same for y so after
this you will have uniform objects after
running this constructor which have
prototype of points and x and y
properties and this this class is all
you need to know for caching because
yeah if you get another object of this
type you already know where you're going
to find X and we're going to find y this
is not completely solid it is possible
to break this I did some benchmarks in
this this is the results one noticeable
thing was that both Firefox for an IE 9
don't seem to catch lookup meshes so if
you're looking up a property that
doesn't exist it's pretty slow probably
because some people consider this a
programmer error depends on what you're
doing I've always happily looked for
properties that don't exist in objects
but maybe I should stop doing that
because you pay a small performance
penalty there's deep prototypes change
which are not handled that well the
Firefox actually deleted property from
an object that's pretty hard to get back
to some valid class then again because
you can delete any property sure they
have to be a lot more clever than just
dealing with edit properties both
Firefox and opera didn't deal that well
with it and then I tried just generating
more and more variants and at about ten
most caches seem to break down if you
have ten variants of an object's running
through your loop that's actually
already pretty rare you yeah you don't
usually do that or was striking when
doing this that was almost impossible to
break the v8 caching I don't know what
they're doing maybe I should tweet
through the code somehow because it's
apparently very clever next as a small
note at the end there's type inference I
don't think this is being done on a very
large scale yet but people are talking
about it and it's very promising and it
will probably be the next big gain for
for JavaScript performance traced
compilation already takes it's a bit
into account but it's completely runtime
dynamic there's actually also a lot of
static information about types that you
can glean from from a JavaScript program
here's a trivial example if we take the
I variable is being mutated in two
points because it's a local variable we
can prove that these are the only two
points that are mutated mutating it and
they both set it to a number starts at
zero and then this increment it's in the
increment operation leaves it a number
so given that we know that I will always
be of type number so it means you can
for example optimize this this
comparison less than you could even
optimize the array look up the code that
the output yeah the code that the
compiler outputs can be a little smarter
because it knows that I is
of type number there were optional type
annotations being talked about in what
was supposed to become a confused for
I'm actually kind of sad that those
vanished because they would they would
help compilers a lot even if other
compilers choose to ignore them and well
you don't have to use them if you don't
want them but I think they would be a
great addition of course there are other
cases if you have Global's then the
whole program can change your type and
it's very hard to prove that they are
going to be of a certain type same with
properties with objects being passed
around everywhere function return values
you need whole program analysis to to
get any kind of reliable information on
these kind of values that's exactly what
what Brian Hackett at Mozilla is
currently doing and it sounds like it's
it's going in the right direction and
it's very promising I don't know how far
other browser vendors are are with this
but yeah it's probably going to work to
a certain point what he talked about was
that you have to dynamically update
sometimes and recompile some code if
your assumptions about types are broken
like anyone can do an eval which changes
the type of global and then well you
have to go back and recompile some code
so it's it's very involved but it helps
it speeds things up more that was all
I'd be happy to take questions if anyone
has one no questions thank you
you know there are planes for us we
didn't have to take a wagon to organ